on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome to piers morgan and censored
with me jeremy kyle coming up tonight
another bombshell race claim from megan
if there's any time in my life that it's
been more focused on my race it's only
once i started dating my husband
then i started to understand what it was
like to be treated like a black woman
but is any of it actually true or is
this just the usual megan's truths
street party or bloodbath is it time for
the last float to leave the notting hill
carnival and pubs and schools are
running out of money and in 19 days my
friends you may too we'll have top tips
on how you can beat the cost of living
crisis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends and welcome to
uncensored now it surely cannot be a
coincidence with morgan as safely a
sconce on his luxury yacht but meghan
markle has decided to produce some of
her finest work i reckon she does it to
wind him up you know morgan's on holiday
let's make the old man choke on his
fresh oysters on a serious note in the
week when we should all be focusing on
princess diana and her incredible legacy
25 years on the global media instead
reporting megan comparing her marriage
is unbelievable to nelson mandela's
release from jail now today mandela's
own grandson slammed markle for equating
the culmination of nearly 350 years of
struggle with the celebration of her
wedding and if that wouldn't have got
morgan heaving overboard this afternoon
this is just ridiculous a new episode of
megan's podcast archetypes dropped with
special great guest mariah carey here's
a teaser with a warning hope you're not
in the middle of your dinner
if there's any time in my life that it's
been more focused on my race it's only
once i started dating my husband then i
started to understand what it was like
to be treated like a black woman because
up until then i had been treated like a
mixed woman
i'm now joined by royal commentator and
biographer angela levin talk tv
commentator afia hagan and royal expert
from the u.s kinsey scofield ladies
welcome um
let's start with my friend angela levin
is it me or the majority of the british
people that are wrong what is this woman
up to what is her motivation for
continually it seems drawing attention
to herself whilst kicking the very
institution that that has been
long before her and will last long after
i don't i don't get it well i think it's
quite simple actually and it's not just
the uk it's happening all around the
world of people who are seeing right
through her i think her aim is to get
rid of the
british royal family without a doubt
and part of that is because she has to
win
she fights and fights and goes on and on
until she wins wins what well she wins
her battle she didn't think she was well
treated there in fact what it was of
course was that she wasn't used to it
you can't change your country change
your family change your job come into
something that's very unusual and decide
within five minutes you want to make
them modern and they should listen to
you and she should be number one they
should make her very very famous and
concentrate on all her beauty and her
brain and all the rest of it
without giving anything a chance uh if
she stayed there it might have been
helpful and have been sensible and
fitted in but she won't because she
wants everything her way all the time um
if i could bring in kinsey schofield
from america thank you so much for
joining us kinsey um the americans are
famous for loving the royal family and i
don't even know why i did that accident
um just explain to me
when when this i mean the new york post
today toddler and tiara has made it
pretty clear what they think of this
woman
are american people's views of her
changing are they supportive because
today she's played the race card again
i do think that they've changed because
america is really struggling right now
with inflation gas prices politics i
mean everything is so polarizing so when
meghan markle sitting in her mansion
goes on tv to complain about the you
know becoming a princess and having all
of this attention and this platform
given to her by her in-laws i do think
that perception is changing in america
and we're a little bit more critical of
her after the oprah interview we all
sympathized with her we wanted to take
them in we wanted to protect them but we
talked about that a year ago there's no
reason to continue on with that story
what does she have to say what is what
are her morals what are her values and
what are her objectives we need more
from megan than continuing to obsess
over the past
i completely agree i fear hagen um i
know that you see it differently i
appreciate you being on the show what i
don't get about meghan markle is
are we saying that she didn't realize
what she was marrying into she seems
very uh to me to to be dead set on this
course of destroying in her mind the
royal family she seems to have a very
high opinion of herself and and if you
as angela said you judge the global
reaction to this
there's real anger
real anger i think there's faux anger to
be honest i think actually
what angela said was right she wasn't
used to it absolutely she's changed jobs
she's just got married she's had these
huge life changes uh marrying into the
royal family it was a huge thing for her
but she always wanted that she always
wanted that she was outside buckingham
palace eyeing up the royal family years
and years ago do you not go with the
people who say she had this completely
laid out this is a plan to get with this
boy who's had all sorts of issues and
has as we all know had problems right i
mean prince harry right now in the
united i mean i i was watching something
today they were saying these two should
be stripped of their titles and and sent
away
how can you still trade on something
that you spend almost every day slagging
off that's what i don't get look meghan
markle is talking about her experiences
when you talk about playing the race
card that's unfair because there is no
such thing as playing the race card she
as a mixed-race woman is talking about
her experiences which affects her every
day unfortunately you can't choose that
so it's not playing a role right okay we
know each other but no no no no no it's
about talking about her experience all
right it's about her experience kinsley
finished so i'm going to finish as well
it's about talking about her experiences
as
you asked do i think that she planned
every moment of this no i don't i don't
i really really don't know
who spend a lot of time reading between
the lines where there is nothing to read
she gave an interview
and the headlines were
that's
extrapolated
to say that she's been absolutely
ghastly her time has been totally
inappropriate when harry's grandfather
was dying in hospital and she knew and
harry knew they'd been told she had two
weeks or three weeks to live she still
went and talked on up for a win-free
show that is disgraceful to upset him
and upset the queen well what her father
was doing i agree so let me you say i
said about the race thing and if there
is any form of racism you know me we've
known each other a long time in any part
of the world disgusting and wrong but
here's what i get
she's that upper own i'm sorry i'm going
to say it backside she has the temerity
to say that my wedding to a prince and i
take kinsey's view in the middle of a
global economic recession where families
are struggling she says and i quote me
getting married i was told it was as
important as nelson mandela his grandson
today says who the hell does she think
she is come on that's again we also need
to talk about the way this feature was
written and the way that a lot of these
quotes have been done angela i let you
finish so i'm going to finish as well a
lot of these coits have been
extrapolated for their own kind of
generating their headlines what she said
was a cast member of the lion king said
to her
she is not comparing herself to nelson
mandela why mention it
member of the lion king said to her that
this moment in time was like that she's
not comparing herself to nelson mandela
if you read the next line it says she
knows okay she's known nelson mandela
okay let's bring she's not good let's
bring healthy do that let's bring kinsey
back in from the u.s desperate to speak
kenzie oh i'm so sorry i but i i just
have to stress meghan markle is a savvy
woman she has gone through press
training she's gone through royal press
training this is a woman that knows how
important sound bites are the writer
even acknowledges that she speaks as if
there's a bachelor producer living in
her head she knows what these reporters
are going to take away and turn into
headlines she knows the talking points
and quite frankly she is so important in
the united states that she could say
this is off limits and this is off
limits megan knows exactly what she's
saying and what she's doing i think the
woman is very intelligent so i think
it's silly for us to say oh she had no
idea that people were going to pull
certain headlines she is very skilled
and very savvy and was probably some pr
guru in another life
conniving well can i just say all of us
would agree and this is what really
winds me up of fear right
tomorrow is 25 years
since the princess diana died okay the
tragedy that rocked the world right her
two sons left without a mother you
cannot convince me we could sit here all
night and say that yet again meghan
markle's timing don't tell me it's a
coincidence she wants the world to be
talking about her instead of diana
that's her problem that is it she sees
herself as diana number two she sees
herself as an alternative dana she wears
diana's perfume when she was with harry
she was saying that all sorts of things
that she's very close to diana harry
said he thought his mother would they
would be best friends i mean she's
planning herself to be another diana
because she thinks she's like her
because she also felt that she was um
treated badly of course she wasn't it
was a whole different sort of i would
love to know and she and she loved the
royal family but she couldn't cope with
it i would love to know a fear yeah you
can but can i just say this i would love
to know what diana princess of wales
would have made
michael i agree with you yes sofia
you're sure i can answer no thanks
angela you know i think it's really
disappointing actually that this has all
happened around this time because i
would love to be talking to you more
about diana's legacy about 25 years
since she passed about where we all were
when it happened yeah about you know she
was a fashion icon she was an icon of
philanthropy yeah about the legacy she
leaves yeah
why has it happened because meghan
markle has let it out now and you cannot
affair with the greatest of respect
she is savvy kinsey's right she knows
what she's doing she has released this
the cut and that ridiculous podcast to
have a much million she's paid for that
on the eve of the death of his mother
and i am astounded that prince harry
does not have a pair big enough to say i
love that was my mother come on but
you've got no courage to say anything
against her he will lie because um he
doesn't want to upset her she will just
let her do everything and she's made a
total wreck of him i spent a year and a
quarter with him hang on the second if i
if you could i spent a year and a
quarter with him and he's totally
changed he's just become resentful and
aggressive and he's she's taught him how
to hate his family he got on very well
with prince charles they had their
problems earlier on later on they were
very compatible and she's just destroyed
him and i think he's up a terrible
terrible situation at the moment at the
end of the day he's a grown man she's a
grown woman they're a married couple i'm
pretty sure that they had discussions
around the timing of the release of the
podcast you know um
you don't know that angela because
you're not
married to answer the question do you
not think the fact that it was released
on the on the anniversary almost the eve
of the anniversary of princess diana's
death shows complete disrespect and
absolutely nails in most people's minds
what a manipulative woman meghan markle
i have to say that when it comes to
meghan markle she cannot do right for
doing wrong then shut up and don't say
anything whenever she released this
podcast would be the wrong time whenever
she gave the interview
or any other magazine would be the right
thing all right let me just say okay the
queen is so ill i agree
why do it an upset here's what i don't
get kinsey if i could bring you back in
i've said this from day one since they
went to california my old man worked for
the royal family i have a strong
affiliation but i'm also intelligent
enough to know there are two sides when
they both said and i quote and i've said
this to you before of fear we don't want
anything to do with the royal family we
want to go i went do you know what fair
play go to california have your life
happy kids but when you get on a plane
saying the press intrusion is disgusting
and the minute you land you sign a 112
million dollar deal with spotify when
anything you do is actually a dig at the
royal family and your timing is
seemingly always fantastic no wonder
people in this country and across the
world are cynical
i mean i can't argue with you prince
harry and meghan markle have an
incredible platform prince harry could
be branded as a
zuckerberg or a barack obama a thought
leader not i'm not saying he's going to
be a president but he could be a thought
leader but if they are obsessed with
their past and they can't move forward
and they don't have any original ideas
all they're doing is hindering
themselves they have got to stop
attacking the british royal family and
they have got to find their own identity
i fear
i actually think that's what they're
trying to do you know when megan's
talking when she when she's let's take
the podcast archetypes where she's
talking about the different words that
are used against women and yes she does
talk about her own experiences but she's
talking about new topics as well you
know serena williams retiring she's
going to talk about producing television
and films with issa rae and mid decaling
i think yes that is one way of them
moving forward and moving forward from
the past and actually do agree with
kinsey that they need to do that that
they need to produce
i think when it comes to them attacking
the royal family there's lots of people
that will read between the lines where
there's no lines to be read between and
will extrapolate the headlines that they
want to generate the case that they want
the newspapers
if that's the case you will not convince
me that she doesn't know that people
will read between the lines that she
doesn't know that every time she opens
her mouth she's going to get a reaction
when she talks about the royal family if
she talks about the royal family then
it's oh my goodness how dare she talk
about the royal family we'll talk about
it
if she doesn't talk about the royal
family why would she not reference the
royal family at all at the end of the
day it's literally this simple meghan
markle and harry cannot do right for
doing wrong that's their own fault final
word from you angela well when they left
the royal family they had everything
they wanted they had a big house they
had lots of money coming in they then
had two children one of each they were
so happy 16 toilets mandela didn't have
one in his 27 years of being in prison
um and they should be happy but they're
they're full of bile and nastiness i
will horror i will appreciate
everybody's opinion of fear yours
certainly is yours angela as well i
think what's really interesting about
the british people um the british people
in fact that the people across the world
will make their own minds up for me yes
of course she has a platform and yes of
course she has a right to talk but i
will not be changing my mind that the
timing the timing of meghan markle's
outburst via podcast or whatever is
always to do the ultimate damage to an
institution i believe in right next to
an uncensored carnival of carnage one
death six stabbings 200 arrests and more
than 70 officers assaulted the question
we talk about next is it time to ban the
notting hill carnival we're coming right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now the
notting hill carnival is without doubt
the biggest street party in europe
more than two million people attended
this year's celebration of the black and
caribbean community in what was the
biggest bash since the pandemic but
sadly the event slowly descended into a
scene of chaos these people are having
fun dancing on top of a bus stop until
it collapses onto people walking past
random acts of violence in broad
daylight and last night a man was
stabbed to death in clear view of
hundreds of people and police the victim
has been identified as 21 year old takeo
nembard the rapper had traveled to the
event from bristol with his sister and
was expecting a child with his
girlfriend now after this festival of
violence
should next year's carnival be cancelled
right now uh many opinions joining us
are ken marsh chair of the mets police
foundation or federation which
represents more than 30 000 rank and
file offices in london uh former chief
superintendent with the met dr victor
elisa and comedian and regular carnival
attendee dane baptiste can i start
please with you dane
what does the notting hill carnival mean
to you can i just caveat that by saying
of course we saw this violence and
people are jumping up and down but we're
seeing this all over the united kingdom
at the moment in all sorts of things
yeah i think i would even go so far to
say that if you remove the flags and the
hue of the uh footage should be seen it
would easily look like a football parade
or like this uh scenes reminiscent of
what we saw at the euros um so for me
what carnival means to me is an
opportunity during the year for uh first
and second generation caribbean
immigrants particularly the windrush
generation to celebrate their identity
their culture
and um maybe to have a rebuttal against
what exists as dominant culture and most
importantly uh the carnival exists as um
kind of a i suppose an affirmation of
humanity following like actions of
brutality against caribbean immigrants
so i think it's a celebration of all of
that a reclamation of humanity and
identity and uh yeah the celebration but
mostly something very fun um ken you've
been quite vociferous and have said it
should be banned can i again caveat with
the same thing that i said today
uh the horrors in liverpool people
attacking people in leeds in broad
daylight with machetes it was an
absolute tragedy that that young man was
stabbed and there were acts of violence
but this is happening all over the
united kingdom why should the notting
hill carnival be cancelled well because
we're faced with a situation where year
after year other than covid i end up on
a tuesday morning after nottingham
weekend where 70 80 100 of my colleagues
have been seriously injured
they don't ask for that to happen they
don't go to work thinking that's going
to happen on top of that we've had
dozens of knife seizures that this
so-called happy weekend that we're faced
with we have groups who turn up with one
intent that is to cause harm to others
the vast majority as quite rightly has
been pointed out are law abiding systems
but we cannot keep having this situation
every year year after year after year
it's disgusting where my colleagues have
no choice they are made to do what
they're doing and they face danger every
bank holiday i'm not i'm not ken in any
way negating that uh victor um
i i tried to say in in a balanced way
that this is pretty endemic of
everything across the united kingdom at
the moment are you were you upset used
to serve in the met were you upset with
the levels of violence do you think
that's the norm nowadays do you think
notting hill should be banned what's
your view on this well let's work
backwards i don't think nothing else
should be banned
um what we're seeing at the moment and
and you mentioned it jeremy what we're
seeing at the mall we've had 18 months
of people
movement constrained yeah the pendulum
was always going to swing the other way
yeah i'm not saying that's a that's the
next explanation or justification so not
inhale is symptomatic of what we're
seeing at the moment you know a violent
response to 18 months two years of
people being locked down don't get me
wrong no one should assault a police
officer whether it's a at a festival
whether it's on a friday saturday night
and if they do they should pay the price
how do you answer what ken said about
his colleagues how do you answer that
talk to him
two million people yeah by the law of
averages you're going to have something
friday saturday night cops will be
assaulted that's not a justification
there should be
and there ought to be better planning
look
we can't prevent everything any cop
being assaulted but what we can do what
we ought to be able to do is say to
everyone who's turning up if you're
turning up to enjoying yourself fine if
you're turning up to cause trouble
there's enough cctv in here we'll track
every single movement we may not get you
today but we'll be back to get you vic
with the greatest respect we do that
every year you know that because you've
done it and you've been out there that
is not the answers are not in what
you've just said the answers are we need
to come to a decision now as to why we
are allowing this every year to continue
and i sit here on another studio every
tuesday after nottingham weekend and
talk about my colleagues who have been
seriously assaulted and we can talk
about other events where it happens as
well i accept that but this is one where
we don't choose for this to happen we
don't choose for the public purse to be
spent in this way tens of millions of
pounds are spent on policing thousands
and thousands of police officers have to
police this event it's not a private
event it's a public area so we have to
because we get the blame if we don't get
it right we have to make sure that we
have everything in place the planning
goes on all year round but still we are
faced with this because people go there
for one reason how do you respond to
that people go there for one reason um
i'd say um to say people go to is quite
a broad term especially when you look at
the numbers i mean of the maybe 1.3
million people that attended over the
course of the weekend maybe about 200
arrests which and kind of works out
about 0.0025
as opposed to somewhere like leeds and
reading where you had maybe a hundred
thousand attendees over the course of
that weekend and you had no point not
for that population being arrested so
let's talk about that the leads and
reading festivals and i'd say one of my
daughters was going to go until i said
beginning and and i totally agree with
you it seems unfair
percentage but they go there for one
reason that very small percentage you
cannot deny that because it happens i
don't deny it but it's something that we
can't conflate that with carnival goers
because if we were if we were to
where if we were to ban it for example
then you wouldn't dispel this element of
criminality somewhere in a safe area
hyde park fence it off put everyone in
there sterilize it so that you can't
take drugs yeah but we've seen them in
hyde park we've seen um instances of
stabbings i'm sure you've seen the viral
videos as well yeah so i don't think we
can like move events around the issue is
that we have an element of criminality
which i would say is more of an issue
that relates to poverty a cost of living
crisis and maybe some of the more
punitive or rehabilitative measures that
have been taken to treat this element of
criminal of youth violence or
criminality have not been particularly
effective i'd say again if you can
reverse engineer it and it's maybe
addressing these issues before these
elements arrive at carnival because look
at again going back to numbers as far as
i'm concerned even if my issue is with
this conflation of caribbean culture and
with violence because if you were to
take the populations of the british west
indies and countries like grenada
barbados even if you grouped all of them
together they still wouldn't equal the
amount of people that attend carnival on
the weekend you know how many fights my
colleagues stopped over the weekend
hundreds not a few hundreds because they
were there because the amount of police
officers i mean that's fine but that's
that's exactly but that's why that's how
law enforcement is supposed to work now
this is very different the carnival
there are no barriers to entry at
carnival anyone can attend whatsoever
exactly when you're talking about 1.3
million people like in numbers that is
the equivalent of a small city within a
small city you have a small element of
criminalization sorry not stopping
yourself yeah
look what we're talking about here let's
not
conflate mistake carnival for people
assaulting police officers police
officers get assaulted friday saturday
night
no no no no no no it's not okay at all
you know in safe events we should be
concentrating on stopping those people
who assault police officers
it's not because of carnival that
assault them those people turn out not
to enjoy carnival to cause problems
unless i'm missing the point
and i'd probably think this differently
than i thought i would
it would be fair to say that there is a
criminal element wherever they come from
in whatever city at football matches
with machetes in leeds in liverpool at
carnival at concerts at festivals surely
the police's job with the community's
help is to weed that criminality out get
the weapons off the street and make
everything safer i guess the question is
is it a wrong look to say because i do
take your point you know
1.3 million people i'm not in any way
the poor man lost his life he's
expecting a child for goodness sake
but 1.3 million people if i said to you
that in a city over a weekend one person
was stabbed to death it sounds a
terrible thing to say
you'd say that's pretty normal
wouldn't you no no i wouldn't say that's
pretty normal normal's not acceptable
normally is it
look at the footage with the machetes in
leeds attacking police officers i'm in
the met and i represent met officers not
lead so i totally get what you're saying
but yeah if we come back to notting hill
carnival it's not acceptable where we
are because it's year after year after
year after year and it's every year that
i sit here with this conversation and
every year i get the same language that
comes out they're all fun loving it's
1.3 million but we don't choose to be in
this situation and i know our job is to
enforce the law i get that fully but
we've been lambasted from pill at the
post about stop and search about
everything else we do and now we're
faced with these scenarios where we're
up against it and my colleagues are
being challenged which is uh which is a
really salient point and needs to be
answered absolutely i agree it's a
salient point but it's a point that you
can't come to the public for that we we
pay into a tax base in order to provide
this resources for our law enforcement
so if law enforcement have a lack of
resources or training or uh logistical
uh resources well there's not enough
police officers are they that could be
that would be honest they're too busy
being mental health workers and social
care workers i'm not arresting people
now i'm going to say something that will
go down like a lead balloon i had a big
debate on the radio some time ago about
stop and search it still got 5 000
weapons off the streets of london last
year yeah i mean that has to be a
positive i mean yeah prevention is
better than cure but then i would say in
instances where we've seen these courses
of positivity and but that's what we're
talking about that's what we should
maybe we need to increase the sentences
of being caught with a knife or a weapon
so we discuss about punitive measures
but we know even in america we have the
death penalty it does not deter or it
does it does not stop people from
attacking people the issue i would say
particularly with the police is that in
their in their interactions particularly
with the caribbean community is that
even if you are taking cautious measures
to do stop and search what doesn't
happen is if when you don't if there's
no criminality or weapons revealed there
is no aftercare from the police
explaining to these citizens and future
voters
i am the speaker for my own direct
anecdotal evidence there is there's
nothing
clearly it's insufficient because this
is one of the reasons why we had
protests two years ago any other person
in this country we are more answerable
for absolutely every single thing
that's true
theoretically it's true because we've
already had the right the head of the
met has already left because when she
was tasked to investigate police
corruption that culminated in the murder
of a citizen in the form of sarah
everyone else she's left well
the point is it looked very dubious at a
time where people were scrutinizing the
police's own corruption are we not for
someone to leave are we not actually
saying that the police because that's
expected to do so many different jobs
under intense pressure are not actually
out in the streets walking the streets
getting intel and meeting the
communities there's resentment from his
workers because they're under difficulty
and there's resentment understandably
which are a carnival that is is meant to
be a celebration i spend so much time in
barbados i think it's an amazing idea
but i also don't like the fact that
people were stabbed and people were
attacked but it's a i have to tell you
it's everywhere across this damn country
i've been going on about it week in week
out and i do have sympathy with the
police because they have no they don't
have any strength in depth and the rules
are you you would understand both sides
of this argument i don't understand both
sides of the argument you know and
my real concern is we've got a cultural
art event that's enjoyed by people
in the uk from across europe from across
the world let's don't remove that
benefit that cultural benefit because
we're confusing that with people who go
and assault police officers let's deal
with people who go into science i agree
with you i have to reduce that and let's
focus on that i have not carnival i have
to finish but i think we would all agree
ken uh victor and you don't you know
people should be allowed to enjoy
themselves but there are problems in
this country and policemen and women are
suffering and maybe the rules need to be
stronger maybe the intel and dealing
with the communities more but really
really appreciate it whatever your
thoughts are home let us know right next
uncensored this is true headline in a
major newspaper today many people in
this country are 19 days from the
breadline dire warnings that spiraling
energy food and fuel bills will leave
millions of families in less than three
weeks being unable to afford basic
essentials this is not just paper talk
this is not just tv talk this is a
really really difficult time for many
many people we'll try and dissect it
we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to uh uncensored now we've
talked about the cost of living crisis
so much over the past few weeks and
rightly but how about this today for a
brutal report from the legal in general
they say the average uk working
household is just 19 days from the
breadline meaning if people were to lose
their jobs today it would be less than
three weeks until many of us ran out of
money now if that wasn't bad enough
schools are being reported across the uk
that they claim could be forced to shut
as head teachers struggle to pay bills
and forget drowning his sorrows even the
pubs are warning of mass closures with
some facing 300 increases in their
energy costs yes it's dire we want to
try and give you some tips joining me
now is ceo of hospitality uk kate
nichols and personal and finance
business expert my mate gemma godfrey if
i can start with uk um
pretty dire isn't it
it's very devastating for many of these
businesses pubs bars restaurants hotels
across the uk have struggled for two
years with covered where they've been
closed uh one in three have got no cash
reserves one in three and not making a
profit and now they're facing soaring
energy costs which they're unable to
pass on and it makes them unviable
overnight they simply can't afford four
or five and today i had one that had a
12 times increase in their energy bills
so overnight these businesses go out of
business people lose their jobs people
lose their jobs the supply chain is hit
communities lose their community asset
where people go to socialize the lonely
and old elderly go in the community to
have a hot meal to stay warm we lose
those vital community assets and this is
the third largest employer in the uk
we're talking about so if they close
down then the whole of the economy also
has an impact what's the answer well we
need to have immediate action from the
government they need to get a grip of
this from day one of the new government
taking effect and we need cash support
to go to those businesses an immediate
cut in vat would underpin the business
viability reduce costs to consumers give
people more disposable income to deal
with their own bill crises and then cut
business rates to give businesses their
breathing space to be able to pay those
bills and go forward and if we don't get
that then we are likely to face a loss
of 10 of our hospitality estate hundreds
of thousands of jobs on the line in
hospitality and the supply chain and the
reason that i wanted kate katie to be
here gemma is you know hundreds of
thousands of jobs the place that focal
point for the community
what you and i have talked about this so
much right but but
what are people supposed to think
wherever they are i mean there's a
government that isn't here we've talked
about that there's a new one on the way
you know in a week
everywhere people turn
and it's not just rhetoric
what can people do what what can we say
to people who are worried that the
energy bill will mean they can't pay
their mortgage or their rent they can't
fill the car up we keep saying it
because it matters to people doesn't it
what message can we send is it just the
end or are there things we can do jim
on the one hand the reason why this is
such a dire obvious situation is that
families are fighting on all fronts and
we hear stories like this the problem
that we talk about companies are
companies but but business owners are
also forced to stop paying themselves
and if they go out of business then
we're going to lose jobs people are
going to lose their only form of income
then they're going to be even less able
to keep up with these rising costs on
all fronts however um you know of course
this is a really dire time and also i'm
not here to give those those tips about
freezing food batch cooking i think
people that are watching this have just
heard what can i can i just say actually
we don't make the production meeting and
i think this is very very important
right we tried right to get a family you
know i call them jams just about
managing right we tried to get a family
on today and we couldn't get anybody to
come on is there still embarrassment
about accepting help is there still i
don't know but in the old days if you
gave tips out people to go that's not me
it's everybody isn't it it's everybody i
think the good news is that nowadays
people see it as more like being savvy
yeah savvy with your money you go
through you can save a bit of money here
why wouldn't you and actually so i think
there is a change in in the culture
because everybody has to do it i agree
at the same time we have this stuff
upper lip we don't like talking keeping
up with the joneses keeping up with the
neighbors and the thing is that this is
affecting everybody across the uk
because what we also saw is that people
are spending a third more on their
credit cards for buying essential goods
they're surviving by maxing out their
credit cards just for surviving so i
think this is a really really tough time
for families but it's also affecting
people's mental health but look there is
things that people can do you've got
more apps that are out there to help
people with food sharing to help people
with um uh being able to get the last
food from shops rather than it going uh
being able to get um fruit and vegetable
that look odd you know you can get that
at a discount so there's things that
people can do also a bit more privately
but i agree i think the big concern is
if people don't speak up don't speak for
help is that that could cause another
rippling effect because we all need to
help each other in terms of
drawing together as a community but also
to try and you know support jobs and
support people's well i completely agree
and and katie bringing it back to you
jobs your industry as you said has had a
terrible two years
and and and had just started back
how do you deal with i mean the human
the human cost of what's happening well
the human cost is extreme you know i
i've got business owners who'll be
phoning me up on a daily basis who are
in floods of tears their whole life's
work going to pot and having to close
down this is not just their business
it's their livelihood it's the place
where they live a lot of people live
over their pub live over their
restaurant and they feel a great sense
of uh
need to look after their teams so there
is a lot of human cost and then the
mental health and well-being is that i
think that's massive
it is but but just knowing that you can
continue to be able to work but the
scale of the crisis that is about to
engulf us both customers consumers
ordinary general public and the
businesses is so immense that we are
going to have to have as big an
interaction as we had with covid to be
able to get through this we're not going
to be able to do it on tips and tricks
for how to save money how to prioritize
we need a big intervention from the
government to get the economy and i
think you're right and because of course
we've had no government we've heard
nothing we have another government
minister or prime minister on the
television saying it will be all right
which would have been nice we've been
wallowing haven't we for weeks sort of
floundering in this you know unsteered
vehicle and it's horrible and that does
add to that mental health and well-being
sense of uncertainty there is no sense
that anybody has a grip and custom lots
of businesses lots of employees just
want to have a little bit of reassurance
that somebody is going to tackle this
and that there is going to be a plan
that's why it's so important that the
new government does come out the plan on
day one last word from you jim well
there also hasn't been any support at
all for businesses and also what we're
looking at here is for the last 40 years
we haven't had any increases in prices
or any increases in interest rates
there's a completely new way of managing
money so people do need to be more
supported um thank you and for the
people who say you know while you keep
talking about the cost of living crisis
that's because as as katie says and
gemma knows it is going to engulf us all
but then when we talk about it try and
be constructive try and do whatever we
can but it's about it it's about being
aware of it and and everybody joining
together gemma kelly thank you very much
indeed i'm looking forward to this
coming up on uncensored tv legend kev
o'sullivan has to delegate himself
has allegedly never kissed a tory grace
blakely is pleading the fifth more on
this breaking news story next on
uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back my friends to uncensored
now we've got so much to cram in tea
sets t-shirts and kebabs just as
journalists tonight so she saw the grace
lately and talk tv host and legend kev
o'sullivan hello team um what's the
t-shirt help me out you've been tweeting
what is this i mean like
i just find it all very silly like it's
obviously just a joke you know it was
lucy powell was it who initially bought
the t-shirt she wore a t-shirt saying
i'd never kissed a tory where is the
tree oh hold on a minute here we go and
then twitter explodes people erupting
with rage saying i can't believe that
you're saying that you wouldn't kiss me
a tory i'm such a nice guy i promise it
just all was a bit much let's do this
what i love about you let's just be
honest what you said to me off air go on
have you ever kissed a tory grace
blakely i'm saying that there are many
occasions upon which i may have kissed a
tory but i didn't speak to them for long
enough to know whether or not that
were
good that's true yes kev you've been i
can't wear that with honestly no you've
never kissed a tory have you uh yeah i
probably have actually yes many times
yes
better looking party than labor i think
i have to disagree well
nonsense have you seen the labour
cabinet i mean i think that the reason
that all of these people particularly
conservatives were so angry that she was
wearing this t-shirt saying i'll never
kiss the toys because they all want to
kiss come on
it wasn't me it was a very cruel thing
to say but when lucy powell appeared on
twitter saying never kiss the tory they
said that the membership party of the
tory party shot up rocketed millions of
men signing off right um let's just go
through as many stories as we can team
meghan markle um we had a bit of a
barney at the beginning of the show me
and afiah hagan um
she says meghan markle whatever she says
whatever she does will be vilified she
and harry i cannot get away from the
fact whether she's manipulative or she's
having a hard time every time something
matters she seems to drop it and slag
off the royal family tomorrow should be
about princess diana's death 25 years
ago shouldn't it kev and it's not about
laughter absolutely i mean she's a
shameless opportunist uh bordering on i
think a kind of mental illness a self
obsession that is extremely weird uh
we've only just got over the trauma of
learning that her and serena williams
have a terrible time being a very
successful multi-millionaires women
she she creates a narrative
around everything to turn herself into a
victim you know oh
i'm the victim of racism people don't
like ambitious women there's a racist in
the in the royal family who attacked me
well who are these people name them or
shut up grace
i mean i preface every conversation
about this with the same thing which is
that i'm a republican i can't
particularly bring myself to care all
that much more about what meghan markle
or any other member of the royal family
is doing any more than i should care
about what kim kardashian is doing i
just don't care what cleveland
kardashian's no surprisingly i have a
lot of other things to care about rather
than i just random celebrities
i don't think i just don't
i said it earlier if you don't be in the
royal family i salute you go to
california i salute you but don't
disappear saying you're concerned about
press intrusion take a deal from spotify
and spout rubbish just keep quiet you
know i saw the scale of the deal that
they um that they've got for spotify i
think another one with netflix and it is
just extraordinary it's like huge
amounts of money and i think it is
understandable the people who are going
through a course of living crisis are
going to look at that and think you know
it's very rich she's going to stay lying
at the same time you know i think it's a
bit bizarre to speculate about her
mental health
yeah she's no idea
lying she should stop for example saying
that the press called archie
the n-word it's absolutely not true but
like you don't know whether or not
that's true it's a lie the pressure
never called the n-word the british
the british in the end when did that
happen grace
literally like not at all
what would you have to do no no no
that's something
that's a lot let me speak that is this
always let's not treat this as well
i just struggled to see how anyone could
get so animated over something so
trivial listen i have eight cups of tea
a day apparently this cuts an early
death do you drink tea kev uh well yeah
i can grace would you like it i love tea
yeah do you have you're a coffee man
that doesn't surprise me someone has a
lot of excess energy clearly well maybe
maybe you should kiss him if he's got a
lot of exercise
maybe you need to go beyond that i don't
know and also did you see this this was
extremely funny the man eating a kebab
in front of a vegan have you seen this
did you watch this video did you see
this i did indeed i mean it's it's it's
extraordinary can we have we got this
can we play this just have a watch of
this
he's eating this kid
your manhood's unimpressive that keep
absolute disgrace
here's his favorite subject vegans what
do you mean are you a vegan or a
vegetarian i'm not a vegan or a
vegetarian i mean you know i sympathize
with the fact that we do probably need
to eat less meat if we're gonna be able
to climb climate breakdown do you not
eat me brilliant three kebabs please
governor a cup of tea oh hello rob rob
the gobs on how are you son so look at
now look good luck can i just say that
this has actually been right this is
actually been in this building
how long have we got to fill
minutes take you that long to eat it um
you're gonna be right three
talk amongst yourself but don't talk
about motivation i mean you can just
carry on chatting if you want okay i'm
nice to each other i love not being nice
i'm being very pleasant what do you want
us to talk about while you eat your
cabbage boris johnson's fair welter he's
going to endorse it yeah i mean it's
having trips now that's easy for you to
see
what do i think about boris which is
about things you need to ask me myself
the question we'll ask you grace what do
you think about boris johnson's farewell
tour no well i think that actually he's
left the country in a complete and utter
state his kind of self-pitying um tour
around the country saying oh poor me you
know everyone should think about all the
wonderful things that i've done and i've
been kicked out very unfairly is
completely ridiculous with you all the
way grace we uh absolutely there we go
and here here he is uh signing off i
mean i i was a supporter of boris i
hoped he would have done better um
he's chosen to spend his last month on
holiday as prime minister shouldn't have
been there yeah he should have been
there for us and he goes off saying oh
we'll keep the green project up keep
paying these green levees people can't
afford it boris and he also says i was
right on the lockdowns who do you think
you're kidding boris you were wrong do
you think he'll ever believe he's wrong
because some people will say and i quote
but he genuinely believes you tried
doing this to the kebab in your mouth
i'm being honest
um he actually believes that a lot of
people do that he will make a comeback
that will be the envoy to ukraine for
liz trust greasy fingers uh but he will
make a return that would be make you
happy wouldn't it as a [ __ ] love
him to come back boris johnson has made
a career out of kind of you know getting
through various different scandals he's
lied during his careers he's had all
sorts of scandals that have plagued him
and he's always managed to make any
comeback yesterday he always managed to
come back i mean i wouldn't be surprised
if he does because there is a sense of
entitlement among members of the british
study they just think they're born to
rule i think he's got a great he's going
to come back he's got a great career
ahead of him and a handy phrase in that
career you just give kevin
would you like fries with that that's
what he's going to need
no thank you right well all i can do is
shower at me that's a good reason not to
give up
thank you very much today for watching
we're back tomorrow
this is my kebab as piers always says
whatever you're up to make sure you keep
it uncensored i'm out of the chip see
you tomorrow
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big stuff this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm holly hudson an inquest
into the death of nine-year-old olivia
pratt corbel has heard how a police
officer scooped her up and ran in an
attempt to save her olivia was fatally
shot by a gunman who ran into her home
in liverpool last monday the coroner
said she was taken to hospital but her
heart stopped before she arrived
the un has warned pakistan is facing a
climate catastrophe as it launched an
appeal for more than 130 million pounds
of eight officials say a monsoon on
steroids has left one third of the
country completely submerged underwater
while 1 000 people have died
and bristol rovers say they're deeply
saddened to hear of the death of their
former academy player at notting hill
carnival takayo nem pard also known as
rapper to cause stretch died in hospital
after being stabbed last night that's
all for now we'll have more after the
talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you